this will be a very wet holiday for much
of the Midwest
more heavy rain is coming to areas that
already are waterlogged and after a
powerful weekend storms tens of millions
of people face the threat of flooding
with forecasters predicting the storm
system will stall over the region at
least six states are under flood watches
or advisories Iowa is especially hard
hit with nearly a third of the state
under a flash flood watch through the
afternoon
Tony Duke opal is tracking the damage in
the Midwest Tony good morning good
morning the Midwest continues to take a
beating there were multiple tornadoes
over the weekend in Michigan parts of
Wisconsin meanwhile have gotten more
than 14 inches of rain over the past two
weeks alone the flooding there has
caused an estimated 50 million dollars
in damage so far and now those dreaded
words more rain on the way still reeling
from days of damaging weather this
weekend capped off the second wettest
August on record in Wisconsin it's
heartbreaking to see the damage Governor
Scott Walker toured one of the hardest
hit counties Friday after declaring a
statewide emergency last week the skies
opened up Saturday night over Memorial
Stadium at the University of Nebraska in
Lincoln the delay turned into a
cancellation marking the first time in
school history a football game was
cancelled because of weather the
National Weather Service confirmed at
least three tornadoes touched down in
three different counties in Michigan
including in Barrie County where a
twister snapped this huge tree and
brought it crashing down on this home it
doesn't sound like that freight train or
or whatever they say but just sounded
like a real huge wind in Pennsylvania
Lancaster and York counties are cleaning
up after heavy downpours left a
destructive mark in the region officials
in both counties issued disaster
declarations after multiple roads were
damaged during the storm
because if his brain partner than that
here and we've never had this kind of
destruction in Mount Joy were more than
nine inches of rain fell over a three
hour period on Friday damage assessments
revealed some harsh realities every bit
of her furniture is out here she lost
everything that gives her quality of
life now forecasters say tropical air
from the Gulf of Mexico will add to the
intensity of the downpours and may bring
more than 30 days worth of rain to some
areas bianna a soggy start to September
Toni thank you